Podemos valorar solo los resultados de izquierda unida
como si fuéramos 1 ente corporativo
aislado de la sociedad,
sino de ver cuál es nuestra contribución a la sociedad
y yo creo que nuestra
nuestro país es hoy mejor,
y en parte por esa contribución
que también hemos conseguido hacer
desde izquierda unida
y lo hemos conseguido hacer además
con muy pocos recursos.
Esto lo sabéis perfectamente,
nos ha traído muchas,
muchas tensiones
porque hemos tenido que competir
electoralmente y políticamente con muchas fuerzas
mucho más capaces financiera y económicamente
y mucho
y mucho mejor respaldadas en el espacio público
en los 2º de comunicación,
y hemos conseguido
que todo ello lo hayamos logrado desde
1 unidad y 1 cohesión interna,
de la que yo me siento especialmente orgulloso
porque yo siempre he insistido en que la izquierda eh
tenía 1 problema importante
con ese complejo de la vida de Brian
y porque lo había aprendido
como militante de base de izquierda unida.
Viendo lo que pasaba dentro de izquierda unida
y lo que ha pasado en los últimos años,
es que efectivamente
ese complejo de la vida de Brian
nos ha seguido acompañando
pero fuera de izquierda unida,
es decir,
que en izquierda unida hemos mantenido 1 cohesión
eh muy sustantiva
y eh
creo que eso significa que hemos hecho las cosas bien
y estoy muy orgulloso de que ese trabajo
pues lo haya podido encarnar de alguna manera
eh mi propia persona,
sabiendo que es 1 trabajo colectivo,
sabiendo Que eh los liderazgos importan,
no podemos negarlo,
pero no son nada sin lo que haya detrás,
sin esa militancia que es la que la que.
Bueno,
pues se ha deslomado para que esta sea la situación
eh final, que es 1 situación que cierra 1 ciclo
y nos permite abrir otro
en unas condiciones que
no la hubiéramos imaginado.
Por ejemplo en ese 2 015
que es la propia participación de izquierda unida
en ese gobierno de coalición,
en 1 escenario
de reestructuración de nuestro país y de lucha
descarnada contra la derecha
eh política y la derecha eh
que con sus aspectos reaccionarios
está penetrando en todos los espacios del estado,
como estamos viendo todos los días,
en diferentes titulares,
en diferentes dimensiones.
Por tanto, creo que hay que estar muy,
muy orgullosos de todo lo que hemos hecho,
porque es 1 proyecto colectivo.
Y decir también
todo lo que tiene que ver con la organización política
en la forma de organizarnos nosotros
creo que explica,
explica ese consenso amplio
que
que hemos logrado. Es 1 consenso amplio, que no era fácil
porque lo fácil es la discrepancia y la polarización
y después en algunos casos incluso,
pues las peleas imposible de resolver.
Nosotros hemos optado como dirección
por el diálogo dentro de nuestra propia izquierda unida,
por la negociación,
por el encuentro,
por la puesta en común
y somos 1 organización profundamente plural,
que se ha
que ha sabido gestionar estas disputas internas
de manera que ha Fortalecido izquierda unida.
Y creo que esa lógica de cohesión,
de consenso, con todas sus dificultades,
con todos sus déficits, que tampoco hace falta
eh ignorarlos,
porque creo que hay que ser honestos
con toda la situación,
nos ha permitido sobrevivir a todo este espacio